Watch out! Waaa!
Mom!
No, no, no, no, just keep playing. Just pretend I'm not here.
Does the red light mean it's going?
Andy's going to college.
Can you believe it?
Mom, I'm not leaving 'til Friday.
What are you gonna do with these old toys?
Don't you get it?
We're finished, obsolete, over the hill!
Now come on guys, we all knew this day was coming.
We're getting thrown away?
No. No one's getting thrown away.
We ain't ever getting played with.
Hold on, this is no time to be hysterical.
But it's the perfect time to be hysterical!
Should we be hysterical?
Yeah!
Maybe, but not right now.
Come on, let's see how much we're going for in eBay.
New toys!
At last! I'm gonna get played with!
Where's my nose?
Here it is.
Here's your arm.
Give me that. That's mine.
The mustache?
We're busting outta here.
On three: one...
Three!
To infinity and beyond!
To reset your Buzz Lightyear, insert paper clip...
Rex, use your finger!
Did you fix Buzz?
Er, sort of.
Oh, no.
Oh yes! Return of the Astronut.